interesting that and I'll just try to
grossly oversimplified you know then in
our case as part of a bill that's passed
that says okay will loan you 25 billion
loan and that's a capital L on loan not
bailout not gift not give loan you 25
billion and then we come to you know
several months later into a new space
here and all of a sudden an entire other
industry it melts down on a weekend and
and people rush to the table to look for
six seven hundred billion dollar gifts
in and the energy level around that is
so high compared to trying to find out
reasons not to loan us 25 billion it's
fascinating subject and even this
morning flying and I was reading an
article you know all the articles in the
papers in the Wall Street times and USA
Today and I'm not going to quote them
not fair but you know one of the US
senators talking about well I'm not a
fan of the US auto industry it's not in
myself what are you thinking wait what
are you thinking I'm not a fan of the US
auto industry you're not a fan of jobs
you're not a fan of manufacturing not a
fan of technology I mean how can you say
that and again not going to say where
he's from but even from a state that has
auto you know auto plants an auto
manufacturing I'm not talking you know
there's an old word domestic okay
there's now GM and Ford back to Chrysler
since you know their separation from
Daimler but there's a huge automotive
installed manufacturing and job base
with with Honda Toyota with a lot of
manufacturers here this is this is a
significant industry with a significant
impact the employment of this country in
the tax base and and some of the
government officials not all cavalier
attitude this industry's escapes me